your courage still goes into play today
with the second most made threes in
elite takes a lot of who makes a lot of
them you're working on let it start and
it's good for the file doesn't have the
range run but I still think there's a
place for that player in the lead and it
is as an effective that's the world
dirts trying to carve out this year
obviously way different skill set will a
big as a player but the wrong system it
just don't look like beautiful slick
pass
[Applause]
could be some nervy moments perhaps need
a roadway and they need for dirt drops
afoul that's the shot the Bank is open
even during the holidays even on Friday
night Betty and we've seen this shot off
the glass a lot
the one-legged fade you have told us
many times it's a simple game then he
Smith with the ball in the hands of JJ
to orchestrate that and he goes to Dirk
who will let her rip yes sir three
pointer comes out by Luca figuring out a
way to father's a shot without fouling
Warren well is the defender we haven't
seen dirt down to the block too much but
he goes
the game now teams of defending this
goes but that's an outstanding play by
dirk nowitzki shake gilja's alexander is
1 for 6 on floor leucantha paint dirt
with a catch and shoot
yes sir big time believer
[Applause]
the chance again for three the hard way
it might be the first time ever that's a
nice pass by dirt and I'll go into that
left hand which he's very confident in
obviously the body construct role
[Applause]
we lost 10th Street nothing to lose
throughout his career and knows how to
find this buddy there it is basically
penetration you got a duck down
against Dotson spinning in the statue
shines guard
it's time down there will chances of
dirty giving his average tonight off to
a pretty good start
nice little turnaround against his
salmon already for dirt now he's got it
on the opposite side of the floor
against his own nine for jerk oh you
know he's feeling pretty good right now
establish himself on the turn to the
baseline
[Applause]
good thing carrots it opens up on the
drive
Lucas swings it to dirt
[Applause]
there's a swing over to Dirk after the
rebound absorbed his shove from malcolm
brogdon no mouse ball deep change no see
cast up the shop threw the ball away
[Music]
he'll weigh it in with a foul he could
tie up the game
I like that comparison here's dirt
[Applause]
they play with all their pace and such
that they take care good care the Volvo
teacher an older scan
there's J chain op slang and Kourtney
leagues hangover to trade at 33 years
old crowd do it for the three-ball
ratandas Lucca finds Nowitzki his second
basket of the night one in a couple of
occasions and three would put it back up
for Dirk it's a 2-2 tie the game then
rattles home off the assist by 10
Hardaway jr. you can still get it done
pick and roll two guys on Hardaway
Julian
quick release for Dirk right there he's
able to turn it on if it's playoffs well
he could up the level
[Applause]
what a suitors bounce first basket until
the houses of the house and
the trap closed these five seconds
together come on and in thanks to guys
like Larry Bird's yourself and others
for showing us hey that's cute
gets it jump shot
Oh watch out back you're not about Yanis
to because your host up one bounce turn
shoots over Crowder before you know he's
spilling go over nine yesterday over for
tonight he's dirt from POW three that is
on the money and it's a member glede in
the third quarter in LA 66 65 pulls out
knock down the three point it was nice
so they're showing it to you twice 25
tonight seventh time this year he scored
25 and a games
receives that nice passive Dirk at score
here's Lucan looking to make something
happen lake flock to the corner he'll
give it up Dirk sidestep to defense to
beat the shot [ __ ] yes sir
do it pick Jackson is gonna come in
Budokan looks like
Dierks got a mouse in the house
situation now over
[Applause]
head to the lane dirt glanced to the
other end a look at the shot clock
always seen that food so many times that
Seminole rugs with lucre practices that
stuff and he scores inside against iman
shumpert for the foul right now you have
to challenge us on the bag Lee came into
the media guys like there's no way this
guy is going by me
but every single time back you got back
which is the best in the league right
now I don't think he moved the rebound
and they gotta stop three shot to quit
three downs nice pass to Hardaway gets
keep three know that skis knock down a
couple triples
[Applause]
to the baseline
cause the dirt
where's that first fit Victor drew
what's this
Devin Harris to direct attention
[Applause]
now it's a switch situation
dirt devil team finds Tim Hardaway jr.
in the corner it's like basketball play
with all eyes on him advice
he is a monster Luka feeds dirt top of
the key again
[Applause]
[Music]
returning to 16 NBA history at scoring
Dirk Nowitzki Jalen Brunson with the
assist the jumper of a cabbage will cut
a mismatch mouse in the house time Quinn
cook the defender dirt shoots over and
that's four to start the game for dirt
to go over 20 points at age 40
and dirk nowitzki and he has put on a
show tonight over the rookie here he is
off the oboe 21 points in the game
hitting that fadeaway
two men action on the right side of the
floor got a mismatch dirt ready to shoot
it over Corey Brewer
with his first points of the game to the
rim barely still able to market now
we're getting a very easy
40 years old over 20 years old and on
the money a big part of it well you see
the turn around right here exclude the
trigger while Bagley mommy has done coal
somewhat wait a sport hot start now and
there's dirt for three yes sir his hands
broke to vist to the last possession a
draw gets is starting Trey Burke right
now draaga CH has four points and five
assists tonight he tried to reach Trey
Burke but not in time only players in
the league this year who have met the
statistical benchmarks then Luca did in
the game on Tuesday night 28 points 12
boards 12 assists broke off a try on a
nice catch by Khalid that he doesn't
finish it is a tip out to the pointer
again the ball fights to go he's a guy
that could fit I think in any situation
I think is really gonna help this team
come playoff time
sure against James in a zone you can
hear the crowd how excited they get any
time there's a touch for Dirk defender
Dirk gets it is this time before the
defense could react and challenge
[Music]
[Applause]
got a rookie guarding Dirk on the block
here's your book turnaround shot make me
a sandwich out of that lunch meats and
the rookie that's this little heart did
have a chance
Luca was in cherry-picking position but
nobody able to get the ball up too late
now they do and it's turned when the
assist Aloka that's a good eye right
season I 18 points in Minnesota's last
game on Monday at lost
nine thing in the air is he wanted games
with a man she saw 604 the number on
that graphic on the Shiner Bock
spotlight if he plays everything be
about Dirk Nowitzki as we ponder what
he's got to do moving forward excellent
pass and there you see the elevation the
game that Memphis one in Dallas is the
difference to the delight of the FedEx
Forum crowd games 23 wins 17 losses for
the mouths
[Applause]
his last shot against a rookie
Bridget long career but but also said
hey this is this is the time the time
that's where the one
we make a shot off the glass I think we
just saw the old statue shot there great
this man's great courier you did not
come here to spend the whole second
quarter with us you made it through
seven minutes that's great you survived
here's a display at the AT&T Center in
San Antonio oh yes oh that's nice
dirty hanging on the rim that's a 50
right there all the judges holes left
ends
it's a dirty Brunson races it down
there's dirt dirt looking for the
numbers tonight here at the end for
devils and a Chance decide
the house closest
never forget your teammate that's a lot
of teammates to remember got a shot
amount man turn around jumper gotchas
write it for jerk tonight well you got a
small on it we've seen them take
advantage of little mouse stop but he
tosses it in darts got eight the third
quarter those is the last one when he
started getting up under the deal those
that weren't already on their feet they
see Dirk up top and Dirk over 20 points
10 rebounds they're gonna take him out
out there's a bit of bowel committee
with 40 6.8 seconds left
the last shot made by jerk and he will
come off the floor for the final time
[Applause]
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content